la pollution en côte d'ivoire ce ne sont
pas 1500 personnes qui ont été
intoxiquées mais plus de 5000 par les
émanations de produits chimiques est
déchargé d'un navire étranger puis
déversée fin août dans les décharges
publiques d'abidjan je rappelle que
trois personnes ont perdu la vie
des experts français sont arrivées sur
place ainsi que la ministre française
délégué à la coopération qui dénonce un
acte criminel
robert une angoisse des manifestants sit
in devant l'hôpital de cocody pour
manifester leur inquiétude et aussi leur
colère les malades victimes
d'intoxication se présente ici pour se
faire soigner mais les moyens sont
encore dérisoire en arrivant vous
demande avec quoi gagner vous tous et on
nous donne des comprimés attendait ont
mené des analyses au gré est ce que nous
demandons des analyses qui vont nous
permettre en fait il vaut la peine est
de déterminer les maux dont nous
souffrons
un plan d'urgence a été mis en place
pour tenter de faire face à la pollution
des déchets toxiques volatiles importés
d'europe déversés dans ces décharges
la france a répondu présent en envoyant
un groupe d'experts dans ce domaine la
ministre de la coopération présente à
abidjan a même parlé d'actes criminels
il y à peu près huit jours de stock de
médicaments et il faut bien sûr aussi
paix pour qu'il n'y ait pas de rupture
pour ses médicaments
donc nous allons là aussi en matière de
santé veillez à ce que
il n'y a pas de problème est que tous
les ivoiriens puissent être traités tous
ceux qui sont malades puissent avoir les
traitements adéquats
on dénombre quatre décès sur les 5000
personnes affectées debomy cement et de
vertiges l'affairé grave et a pris une
tournure politique le gouvernement a
démissionné et l'on cherche maintenant
les responsables assurent sur le sérieux
j'aurai donc à se tester au plus haut
dit que je veux mais impôts mais la
démission de couvrir le scandale dans
l'importation de déchets toxiques arrive
au moment où la situation politique en
côte d'ivoire se durcit elle arrangerait
presque les affaires du président gbagbo
accusé d'entraver le processus de
réconciliation en côte d'ivoire un pays
coupé en deux et qui attend toujours des
élections pour sortir de la crise